and this is the first time we're
speaking to you since the prime minister
um stood in the house of commons and
accepted full responsibility for his
actions on the 20th of may 2020 and
offered the house and the public a
heartfelt apology which reading between
the lines is an admission of wrongdoing
yet you came out straight away and
supported the prime minister why if he
was in the wrong
well i don't accept that he's in the
wrong we are waiting for an inquiry by a
very formidable civil servant sue gray
to conclude to we can't judge what
happened we need to know the facts and
that's what sue gray is doing and sue
gray will produce i'm very sure i'll
report very shortly you know what the
what i support the prime minister in is
his apology he said very clearly that he
understood the upset and the anger that
people felt at what they perceived had
happened and what had been reported but
what we all want is the inquiry to
conclude and and to see what the
findings are from the inquiry i support
the prime minister he did the right
thing yesterday he apologized that
apology was heartfelt yeah it was a
heartfelt apology comes from a place
when you feel you have done something to
apologize for
i asked this question to you because
this is what it all boils down to was it
okay in may of 2020 to have an outdoor
gathering of more than two people at
that time
so as the prime minister said in his
statement yesterday number 10 is a work
it wasn't and that's what it comes down
to
sorry i do want to stick to the facts
here we won't let emotion get in the way
but in terms of facts was it okay in may
2020 to have a gathering in a garden of
more than two people
well the facts are as the prime minister
said yesterday that number 10 is a
workplace and the garden runs across the
back of offices in number 10. that's the
prime minister as he said in his
statement stepped outside to thank
people who had been working for 18 hours
a day together in number 10 who stepped
outside into the garden i'm waiting for
the inquiry by sue gray to report her
findings and then i don't think it's our
place to make judgments until that
inquiry concludes
your office as culture secretary in your
office if there's anything work related
do people bring their own bottle
i'm just trying to get an idea into the
culture where it's okay to have booze at
a work meeting
those those people in number 10 had been
working for 18 hours a day my
understanding is that this took place in
the evening but i don't mean
the country have been working 18 hours a
day 18 hour days some of them nhs
workers and they would have loved to
have had the chance to relax with some
colleagues after work in the sunshine
with a glass of wine
so as i said i'm going to wait and i
think everyone should wait and and
understand how upset the prime minister
is about the perception of what happened
in number 10 and understand he you know
i took as a health minister people who'd
lost their relatives and people who had
been through some very difficult
circumstances and i know how he feels
the upset of some of those people and
what they've been through during coding
okay
yesterday
to meet after work in a garden in a
place of work 30 people were there with
snacks and
alcohol as a health minister
would you have said that was okay
many
i would absolutely endorse as many
meetings as possible during that time
taking place outdoors and as much work
as possible taking place outdoors
though
didn't know that though why did the
health department not come out and
endorse that if that was the case you
weren't allowed to meet more than one
person outside
look i'm here to discuss what happened
in terms of the prime minister's apology
at the dispatch box yesterday which was
genuine heartfelt and sincere i like
everybody else i'm going to wait for sue
gray to go about the inquiry to find out
what happened i know that she's we all
know that she's interviewing people and
and getting together the evidence of
what happened and i'm waiting for that
inquiry and we should all wait for that
inquiry and when it happens the prime
minister will go back to the dispatch
box he will make a statement and that
will be the opportunity people will have
mps and and journalists to question him
and to question the findings of that
inquiry but we must wait for that to
conclude
we will wait for the inquiry and we will
see the results of it but you sound like
you know a bit more about this inquiry
than we do a lot of weight has been
given to it but we don't actually know
that much about it and that's important
because that's what's going to be seen
between the difference of something
being fair and robust
and something being a whitehall
whitewash what are the questions that
are being asked by this inquiry and is
it going to be a presentation of the
facts
is it going to be a presentation of the
facts or will it have some judgment over
what happened
so i know as much as you do about the
inquiry i know as much of the terms of
reference as as you do has been reported
i do know that sue gray who i worked
with as a health minister on the
infected blood inquiry i do know that
she's an incredibly formidable civil
servant and permanent secretary and i
know that she will be thorough and
professional about her work that's
that's as much as i know but i know that
it isn't going to be a white wash
because a a professional and formidable
serval servant doesn't do that it will
she's also in the awkward position
though of investigating her boss and so
many people have come on to say that
this inquiry is independent the mere
fact that she's investigating her boss
doesn't make it independent it makes it
internal and that's an important
distinction
i would say that the the civil service
the the one the one thing which defines
the civil service if it is its
independence from government civil
servants sugree included serve many
bosses and many governments over their
tenure of their their lifetime as civil
servants sue grey boris johnson is uh
is the prime minister but sucre is
independent is known to be independent
as are all civil servants okay um jacob
rees-mogg the leader of the house uh was
speaking um last night and there's a lot
of people a lot of mps that have called
for the prime minister to resign
probably the most prominent the leader
of the scottish conservative douglas
ross jake maurice mock dismissed him as
a lightweight
do you agree with that
look jacob rees-mogg is an incredibly
intelligent and articulate man he's
quite capable of passing his own
opinions during interviews i'm not going
to comment on his opinion all i would
say is that the prime minister is
incredibly
sorry he understands the hurt people are
feeling jacob
by calling by calling himself a
lightweight he is dismissing
his call for the prime minister to
design to resign dismissing its gravity
and its seriousness do you agree with
jacob rees-mogg
look some of the
mps who have made statements over the
last few days have a track record of
consistently and frequently
i have a track record actually of not
supporting the prime minister and at
various opportunities over recent years
since before the general election they
have made similar calls and similar
statements and i think that's all i
really want to say about my colleagues
i would just i would just say again that
you know we really understand the prime
minister really understands how people
feel which is why he's asked for an
inquiry and why we want the inquiry to
conclude as soon as is possible and why
he will return to the state to
westminster to the chamber to make a
statement when that inquiry does
conclude not all the calls for
resignation are coming from people that
perhaps you know have called for his
resignation in the past the prime
minister highlighted his good work in
the house of commons yesterday he talked
about the vaccination program he talked
about more people being in work but for
a lot of mps and a lot of members of the
public this latest party scandal if you
like is
the final strike because to give it some
context from a public's point of view
they're looking at
um
you could call it bending of the truth
from the prime minister with regard to
figures on the side of a brexit bus
wallpaper gate dominic cummings uh their
questionable christmas child care bubble
misleading the queen over suspending
parliament the promises of new hospitals
i could go on i have a long list here um
is the pm careless with the truth in
your opinion
well could i go on could i tell you what
i think the people should judge the
prime minister on the fact that we have
the most open and uh rapidly growing
economy but we have that more people
vaccinated more antivirals more people
tested which allows our economy
should we forgive him bending the truth
in other areas because him and his
government and ministers like yourself
do good work it's a team effort but the
individual failings of the prime
minister are being highlighted here
should we ignore those in favor of the
good work the government does
the buck stops with the prime minister
he takes the difficult positions the
prime minister is the person responsible
for our vaccine rollout but the fact
that we have more testing in this
country than any other country in the eu
the fact that we have more antivirals
the fact that we have 400 000 people
more people in work than we did before
the pandemic started the fact that our
economy is open and one of the fastest
growing people should judge the prime
minister on his record in government on
the fact that he has taken difficult
decisions time after time and we are
benefiting from that we see people today
tripled boosted triple vaccinated with
the boosters able to go about their work
he's taken some of the most difficult
decisions furlough the self-employed
grant scheme all of those things that
he's done in my own sector the culture
recovery fund two billion pounds keeping
that sector is that your constitution
on when they email you i wonder what
your inbox was like from your
constituents after the prime minister's
apology
i i can tell you exactly what my
constituents are saying they are
thanking the prime minister for furlough
thanking the prime minister for the
boosters thanking the prime minister for
the vaccine program they know where the
buck stops they know who takes the
difficult decisions and the extremely
difficult decision the prime minister
took over omicron very recently
they know what they have to no no angry
emails about him breaking rules during
lockdown at the height of lockdown may
2020 we all know the sacrifices all of
us made
you made them as well i did people
watching at home none of them angry
about his actions on may the 20th
i think most people can see what this
government has done and how it's handled
but i'm asking you about your
constituency are they angry have they
communicated anger to you or have they
all been positive well i'm in my comfort
i'm in my constituency tomorrow and i've
spoken to a number of the constituents
who i'll be meeting tomorrow and they've
done nothing but expressed support for
the prime minister support for the
vaccine rollout support for the fact
that their businesses have stayed
standing that their jobs are still there
and that they can go back to work that's
what people are telling me and my
constituency okay they will judge the
prime minister on his record and his
record has been exemplary that's where
people should look at what what has
happened over the past 22 months okay
the prime minister's record is exemplary
on this okay none of your constituents
um angry or getting in touch uh
expressing anger about the act i haven't
said okay i haven't spoken you haven't
really good to talk to you this
afternoon thank you